The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I've been giving
out the money cards
for a few of the lectures,
and two or three questions
came up in those that I
haven't addressed so far.
I'm calling them loose ends.
And I'm going to pick up
a couple of those today,
I think they'll
help you consolidate
the knowledge around the quiz.
So I'm going to tie up a
little loose ends there.
And then the lecture topic
I started last time, which
is making this transition
from thinking about angular
momentum of particles to using
the full angular momentum
equations for
rigid bodies, where
we talk about mass
moments of inertia
and products of inertia.
And that's where we'll
pick up, there again today.
Because that's where we're
going for the next few lectures.
OK.
Let's pick up with a
first example here.
This is on the topic
of basically finding
equations of motion.
And there's been
a little confusion
with people, who have asked
me what do you mean find?
Do you mean solve, et cetera.
And so I'm going to go through,
and just a real quick example,
skipping some of the
steps because my purpose
is emphasizing the steps, not
working out all the details.
So finding equations of motion.
Where does it begin?
One of the really
important steps
is this, determine the
number of independent
coordinates you need.
Because when you've done
that, that tells you,
basically-- it really
starts finding the number
of degrees of freedom.
Should have put this
in a different order.
Degrees of freedom
tells you the number
of independent
coordinates you need.
This is 1, 2, and
then 3, that leads you
to the number of equations
of motion that you need.
So this is really
an important step.
Secondly, draw a
free body diagram.
And third, apply
summation of forces.
External vector equations gives
you mass times acceleration,
and summation of torques gives
you DHDT plus this V cross
P term.
So this is just kind
of the step by step.
So let's apply it briefly.
We've talked a lot about things
on hills, so here's a cart.
It's got wheels
attached by a cord
to a second mass that's sliding.
m1, m2, doesn't stretch
the cord in between.
Let's think of these
things as rigid bodies.
So how many degrees of freedom?
How many possible
degrees of freedom?
For the maximum possible, you
have how many rigid bodies?
2.
How many degrees of freedom
for rigid bodies possible?
6 each.
So we're at 6 times
m plus 3 times
n minus the number
of constraints
is the number of independent
degrees of freedom.
This is the number of rigid
bodies, number of particles,
so we have 6 times 2, 3
times 0 minus constraints,
so this one comes out 12
minus the constraints.
You have to figure out
the constraints quickly.
We're not going to allow
rotation in any of the three
directions on either.
They're on carts, they're
big, they're sliding,
they're not rolling
or any of that.
So no rotation for 3,
no rotation for 3 more.
That's minus 6.
So c equals minus 6, or
c equals 6 for rotation.
And then what else can we say?
There's no-- I'll designate
this the y direction so we
can talk about directions here.
And I'll designate
this x in general.
No acceleration at all in
the y direction, right.
Can't move in the y.
So that gives us
1, 2 for each mass,
plus 2 more, that's
8 constraints
that we've come up with.
Now a 9th constraint is
the fact that these two
are tied together.
And so if you had
just temporarily
assigned a coordinate here,
x1, and another one here, x2,
we know for a fact that x1
has got to be equal to x2,
and that gives you yet
one more constraint.
So that's 9.
So we might just stop there.
We say OK, that's a
total of 9, so the number
of degrees of freedom,
12 minus 9 is 3,
and that implies that you need
three equations of motion.
Some confusion comes, you
know, if something's not--
let me rephrase that.
We haven't talked anything
about the z direction.
I haven't described any
constraints in the z direction.
If this is me in a car and I'm
dragging a sled down a hill,
or I'm in a vehicle and I'm
dragging a sled down a hill.
I don't know if you've ever
been in a vehicle with a trailer
on an icy road in the
winter time, that's
a dicey maneuver, going down a
hill trying to put brakes on.
So this thing could conceivably
move in this direction.
And you can either
constrain it to be that way
to make the problem simple, or
you can just say it's possible,
so we have three
equations of motion,
of which two, for now, the
summation of the forces,
external in the--
since I've got x and y,
z must be this way--
in the y direction.
And we'll make it
in z direction,
this is coordinate system 1,
so this would be z1 or z1.
The summation of forces,
z1, is m1 z1 double dot.
But I'm going to
set that equal to 0,
I just know there's no forces.
So this becomes a trivial
equation of motion.
And I add another one, summation
of forces on the second mass.
This is on m2 in the z2
direction, is m2 z2 double dot,
and we set that equal to 0 also.
So what it boils down
to, I had 3 degrees
of freedom, 2 trivial
equations of motion,
leaving me with just
1 equation of motion
that's going to be meaningful.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If x1 is
equal to x2, would that
mean that the rod has to be
entirely along the x-axis?
So that would mean that--
PROFESSOR: So he
asked if x1 equals x2,
does that mean they both
have to be along the x-axis?
I'm assuming that.
So I really am assuming this
thing's going down the hill.
I'm making a point about
this z direction thing
because it's just
a subtlety that you
have to decide on when you're
figuring out how to actually
analyze the situation.
If you really were
thinking about what
happens when a vehicle is going
down a steep, icy hill towing
a trailer, maybe put the
brakes on, maybe not.
You could probably say
well, unless I really
have a disaster, we're not going
to get rollovers and things
like that.
But you could imagine
that it can get out
of the x direction, right.
It could start sliding into z.
It's probably not
going to go anywhere
in the y, that's still
a good assumption.
So this is about modeling,
and how complicated
do you make the modeling.
You actually have to make quite
a few modeling decisions when
you go to do this, and we
tend, in class and examples,
tend to really
oversimplify problems
so that we can do them.
So I've boiled
this down to where
I'm going to end up with one
significant equation of motion.
And that one's going to say
that the summation of the forces
in the x direction--
and I'm just
going to write mx
double dot here,
not putting down m1s
or m2s because we're
going to have to go
to free body diagrams
to figure out how to apply this.
Free body diagrams.
First mass.
So this is m1 here.
m1g, a normal force, no
doubt a friction force,
I'll call that f1, and
a tension in the cord.
And I'm assuming that tension's
going to always be there.
So if, again, in
a situation where
the trailer starts
overtaking the car
and the rope goes
slack, we're not
going to consider
that one today.
So there's your free body
diagram for the first one
and we're going to need to break
mg into a couple of components.
We're going to need
the slope here,
and that translates
into an angle here.
So there's our first
free body diagram.
And our second free body
diagram, second mass, tension,
normal force, another m2g.
And this one's on
wheels, and we're
going to consider
this one frictionless.
So we don't have any friction
force holding it back.
So the reason I've
kind of-- this
seemed like a ridiculous
simple problem,
but the point I
want to make is not
the solution, not the
particular problem,
but an issue that crops up.
How many unknowns are
there in this problem.
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: Well, you
know n1 immediately,
or n2, or the friction
force, or the tension,
or, for that matter, the x
double dot we're looking for.
There's actually-- you
start off this problem
with five unknowns.
But you're only looking to
derive one equation of motion.
So the fact that we're looking
for one equation of motion
doesn't say you
don't have to deal
with several intermediate
equations to get there.
That's just part of the work.
So this is five unknowns to
start with, n1, n2, f1, t,
and x double dot.
So if you'll find out that the
summation of the forces on y
and the y1 on the first mass,
this one, this gives you n1.
Summation of the forces
in the y direction on m2,
this one gives you m2 directly.
From this flows directly, you
know that the friction force
is mu n1.
See, that's a third equation.
So this gives you one
equation, this gives you
another equation, this
gives you a third equation.
You have 5 unknowns,
you need 5 equations.
So there's 3 of them
right off the top.
So this leaves-- you solve
for the those, this leaves t
and x double dot to solve for.
So now the sum of the forces
on mass 1 in the x direction
says m1 x double dot.
And the sum of the forces on the
second mass in the x direction
gives you m2 x double dot.
And I explicitly haven't
said this yet, what I've done
is, one of my requirements
is x1 equals x2,
and I'm just going
to call them x.
Both of these are
exactly the same,
both masses have to move
with the same motion,
is the assumption.
So that means that x1 double
dot equals x2 double dot equals
x double dot, and
that's what I'm
assuming when I'm writing
down these two equations.
I can write those two equations,
one from each free body
diagram.
I've already eliminated
three of the unknowns.
And now because I have two
equations, each have t in them.
Essentially, you eliminate t
and solve for x double dot.
And if you do that
in this problem,
you get your equation of motion.
You eliminate t, solve
for x1 double dot.
Look at this, and you
just look at things
that doesn't make sense.
This says the total mass times
the acceleration is a system,
it's one system.
Mass times the acceleration
of the center of gravity
of the system, if
you will, has got
to be equal to the sums
of the forces on it.
Well, it's got m1 plus m2g sine
theta pulling it down the hill,
and it has minus m
mu m1g cosine theta
dragging it back up the hill.
And that's the entire equation
of motion, it makes sense.
But the equation of motion,
the thing you're looking for,
is the one that ends up with
this acceleration term in it.
If you have multiple
degrees of freedom,
multiple coordinates--
if you have,
let's say, three significant
equations of motion
that result, there
won't necessarily
be one in terms of
each coordinate.
They'll have the
coordinates mixed in them.
Like we did that that two
mass system with springs
the other day, each equation
of motion had x1 and x2.
They don't necessarily separate.
They're coupled through
their coordinates.
This one, it's one equation
of motion for the system,
therefore you have
only one coordinate.
But that's not generally
true of multiple degree
of freedom systems.
OK, that's your method,
though, for a simple problem.
I want to do a little more
difficult problem that
involves rotation.
And this is the
problem, I'm sure you've
done this problem in physics.
It's a classic problem
that people do.
A disk, a pulley, really,
supporting two masses
rotates about this point,
which I'll call a here.
So at some theta there's
no slip, so theta is going
to be related to movement, x.
And I'm going to assign this
one a coordinate, x1 going down.
This one a coordinate,
x2 going up.
A little foreknowledge
here, because you've
worked the problem.
So I want to solve for
the motion of this system.
Now again, we need to know the
number of degrees of freedom.
So it's the maximum possible,
which is our 6m plus
3n minus the constraints.
And let's think about how
we want to model this again.
This time I'm just going to
model these as particles,
doesn't matter how big they are.
My problem, really, they
only go up and down.
So I'm going to model
them as particles.
This is 6 times 0 plus 3
times 2 minus constraints.
So 6 minus the constraints.
So the issue is really
how many constraints.
Well, we're going to
require x1 equal x2.
Cord's taught, doesn't stretch.
If this thing goes
down, that has
to go up exactly
an equal amount,
and that's one constraint.
In that, leaving us 6
minus 1 is 5, leaving us
with a lot of degrees
of freedom here.
Kind of back to the issue
I was making before,
are there any constraints
in the-- I'll call it
x, y, z directions here.
Are there any constraints
in the y or z directions
on either of those masses?
No, I haven't shown any, no
tracks, no guides, no anything.
So technically, there are
no additional constraints
in this problem.
But if there's no forces in
the y, x, I guess y this way,
and no forces in
the z, I'm going
to end up with two trivial
equations of motion
for this one, 1 in
the y, 1 in the z,
the y, 1 in the z.
So back to this
issue of, there's
a difference between constraints
and trivial equations
of motion.
We're going have 4 to
reveal equations of motion.
So really, again, I'm
going to come down
to one significant
equation of motion.
So I have 1 constraint,
4 trivial EOMs,
and 1 significant
equation of motion.
OK.
Now, because I want to
talk about rotation,
we need to pick a coordinate.
Now I can pick-- I can
either let x1 equal x2
and just let it be the sum
x, a single coordinate,
or theta, the rotation.
I'm actually going to
use x for a second.
But there's 2 obvious ways
to approach this problem.
One is to draw a
free body diagrams
of each of these masses, sum the
forces on each, and how many--
if I do that, how many
unknowns do I end up with?
We can draw the free--
here's the free body
diagram for mass 1.
What's it got on it?
Well, m1g.
What else is acting on it?
AUDIENCE: [? Tension. ?]
PROFESSOR: And here's
the second one, m2g,
and tension acting on it.
So now we can sum,
sum of the forces
equals mass times the
acceleration of each one,
and the external forces
are going to involve t.
So you're going to end up
with how many unknowns?
How many unknowns?
I can write two equations
for the sum of the forces
in the x direction.
x double dot is
certainly an unknown.
What else?
AUDIENCE: t.
PROFESSOR: t.
So I end up with
this other [? end. ?]
So that means I'm going to
have to write two equations,
I'm going to have
to eliminate t,
going to go through
the same thing there.
So I don't want to
bother with that.
Is there another way
to do this problem?
This is a problem where you
can use angular momentum
and not have to
deal with t at all.
So let's set that problem up.
You know that the sum of
the torques about that point
a, with respect to point a,
it's going to be derivative,
and since we're dealing
with particles here,
of the angular momentum
with respect to-- I'll
just call it lowercase
h for particles.
Plus this velocity
of a with respect
to an inertial frame across a
linear momentum with respect
to an inertial frame.
That's the full equation
for sum of torques.
What's velocity of a with
respect to o in this problem?
0.
Fortunately, this is
one of those problems
where you can get rid of
this difficult second term.
So it's just torques as the
time derivative of the angular
momentum.
So we need an expression, then,
for both the sum of the torques
with respect to a.
Let's see, what would that be?
So now the external torques
with respect to-- I'll
finish my-- oops, come here
you-- free body diagram.
So now what I really want
is a free body diagram
of the whole system.
So here's the whole system
created as one thing.
You have a force down, m1g,
another force down, m2g.
Up here you have
some normal force up,
that's the support of the pin.
You have tensions in these,
but now this equation
applies to the system.
The ts are internal to the
system, they are irrelevant.
So I'm talking about this whole
thing treated as a system,
and I'm going to
compute the moments
about point a, which is right
there, where that axle is.
Does n create a
moment at the axle?
Nope, but the m1 and m2
times g create moments.
Sure, OK.
I'm going to have
positive out of the board,
the positive moment,
positive angular direction.
So the torques
applied to this system
are r cross t, so you're
going to end up with-- I
want to summarize these.
An m1g, and I didn't write
the radius on this problem,
but at some radius, capital
R. So the torques that are m1g
are positive minus
m2gR, k hat direction,
and that must be equal to the
time derivative of the angular
momentum about a.
Now we need an expression
for the angular
momentum with respect to a.
Angular momentum
is, in general, this
is a r cross linear
momentum, right.
So R for mass 1 with
respect to a cross
the momentum of that
second mass with respect
to an inertial frame.
And a and the inertial
frame are the same thing,
a sticks in the inertial frame.
But angular momentum
is always with respect
to the inertial frame.
Plus the second piece, which
is R of m2 with respect to a
crossed with p for mass 2 with
respect to some inertial frame.
I'm just going to give
you the results for this.
m1 plus m2 R x dot k.
So x dot is this velocity,
R cross and mass times
velocity is momentum, so
the perpendicular radius
to that is the
radius, R. So it's
Rx dot times m,
shouldn't surprise you,
in the k hat direction.
That's the total
angular momentum
that comes from these two
particles with respect to a.
And taking their
time derivative.
These are constant, that's
a constant, this is not,
this is a constant, but it
doesn't change direction,
so this one is pretty simple.
Now I can set equal the sum
of the external torques, that,
to the time derivative
of the angular momentum,
just to fulfill this expression.
And in so doing, I end up with
a solution for x double dot.
m1 minus m2, m1
plus m2, times g.
Turns out the R goes away.
So one equation, never
had to mess with tension.
This is a pretty nice, direct
way of solving this problem.
If you solve for g here, and
you measure x double dot,
this actually gives
you an experimental way
of determining
acceleration of gravity.
It's actually what this thing
was used for a long time
ago, before they had a lot
of the measurement techniques
and things that we do today.
This is a way of determining
the acceleration of gravity.
So these two masses are
quite close together.
This number is pretty
small, you can, however
accurate your timing device is.
Now, just to mention it, I
neglected something in this.
I assumed something and
I didn't even say it.
What was it?
What would screw up
this measurement?
I'm trying to measure the
acceleration of gravity,
if I built this apparatus, would
I get a very good measurement?
AUDIENCE: The pulley
would have to be massless.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the pulley
I've made an assumption
about that, right.
So how would you
fix up this equation
to account for the pulley?
AUDIENCE: You'd have
to take into account
its moment of inertia.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you'd
put in something.
And where would that
go into the problem?
How would you account its
inertia, moment of inertia
in the problem?
AUDIENCE: ha.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you'd
just put it into ha.
So this expression for h would
end up with one more term,
it's going to look like--
well, when you take the time
derivative, you're
going to end up
with another piece over here.
Some i about a theta double dot.
You're going to have to
relate theta double dot to x
double dot, which you can,
because x equals R theta.
x double dot is R
theta double dot.
You could fix that and you'd
have an equation of motion.
But that means we need
to know about i about a,
that's where we're going to
at the end of this lecture
and for the next
several lectures.
OK.
That's that example, and
I've got two more brief ones
that I wanted to talk about.
Any last questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain again why
you didn't take the
tensions into account
for your sum of torques?
PROFESSOR: OK, so why did I not
take the tensions into account?
So I can write the
equation of motion
for this thing as
a complete system.
One, the masses and
the pulley are all
the same thing, the summation
of the external torques on that,
they're going to amount up to
taking into account the time
rate of change of the angular
momentum of the system.
Now, if I didn't
understand that,
I could have blindly gone ahead
and put the ts in there, right,
they would've been exactly
equal and opposite with respect
to a and it would
have cancelled out.
So either way, if you're not
sure about that assumption,
you could just put
them in and they
would appear in the torque
equation, but as a minus
tR and a plus tR
and they'd cancel.
I want to move on
to a third example,
and this is the third item
that I want to clear up,
loose ends I'm calling them.
The muddy cards
are really useful.
I get questions in those
that spark something.
And this is a question that
came up two or three times
in the muddy cards and
I haven't addressed it,
and that is, we were
working with rotor problems.
And remember this problem.
You have the rotor,
it had an arm,
I did it this way to
make some things obvious.
But this is the z direction,
it's rotating about that axis.
I've got a point mass up here.
r hat, so this is
R-- actually, I'm
going to make it a
capital R so it's easier
to distinguish from the r hat.
And this is z.
This thing's rotating, it's got
bearings here to keep it going.
And we talked about
torques, so this
is my point A. I want to
write the sum of the torques
about A, time derivative
of the angular momentum.
We've done this problem
before, so I'm just putting up
a couple of points
for review to clear up
some possible misconceptions.
That's this term, so what about
point A now in this problem?
What's the velocity at point A?
0, so again we can
get rid of this guy.
I'm going to come back
to this and do an example
one of these days
where this isn't 0,
where it's really handy
to be able to do a problem
where that's not 0.
OK.
This is true.
I need a free body diagram
of our little mass,
so here's my free body diagram.
And it has possibly a
force in the z direction.
That comes from the
rod, there's rods that's
supporting this thing, right.
There's possibly a force
in the z direction.
There's a force in the r hat
direction, in the R direction.
There's a force in theta
direction going into the board.
And there's mg.
All sorts of forces
on this thing.
And the question was asked,
when we did this problem before
and did the time derivatives
of the angular momentum,
we found that we got--
there's three terms
and I'll write them
down here for you.
I'm just saying in advance
what we're going to do.
When you solve this
problem, you find out
that it takes to torque to
accelerate this shaft and spin.
That the driving one,
that's what makes it happen,
makes it accelerate.
We had two more terms that were
torques at this point, that
is what it takes to
support this system.
It's trying to bend out,
it's trying to bend back,
those are torques
that show up here.
And we actually get them
when we work through this.
But we don't get
something that tells us
about the moment
the torque created
this point caused by gravity.
The question was, why don't we
get the torque about this point
caused by gravity.
There's clearly mg down,
there's clearly a moment arm.
So mgR is the torque
about this point.
And if you were doing the
statics problem in 2.001,
there'd be a torque
around this point caused
by the weight of this thing
just sitting there, not
even spinning.
And what we're doing here
gives you no help with that.
But just for the quick
review of this problem,
more in the line of helping
you think about the quiz.
This then is R, we'll
call this point B
and this is point A, remember
this is RB with respect
to A cross p with respect to o.
And that's where our
angular momentum comes from.
In this problem that is r hat
plus z k hat cross m times
the velocity,
which is R omega z.
And that must be in the
theta hat direction.
When you multiply these
out, omega z is theta dot.
They're kind of interchangeable
in this problem.
So when you multiply this
out, you get two terms.
mR squared theta dot k hat
minus mRz theta dot r hat.
Two terms from this.
And when you do the time
derivative of the dhdt,
you get three terms.
mR squared theta
double dot and the k.
Now, why do you get three terms?
Because this term has
two variables in it that
are functions of time,
theta dot has a derivative,
and r hat has a derivative,
because it rotates.
So one of the key
bits of mathematics
you have to learn
in this course,
I'm kind of giving you a
little quiz review here,
you need to know how to take
the derivative of a rotating
vector.
And that's what we
do here, gives us
two terms minus mR z
theta double dot r hat
minus mRz theta dot
squared theta hat.
So three terms in this time
derivative of the angular
momentum, and they have to be
equal to the external torques.
This is equal to the summation
of the torques about A,
the external torques.
Well, you'll need a
torque in the k direction.
That's what it takes to
accelerate the thing,
make it go faster.
This mass has a
force on it to make
it go faster, that's this f
in the theta hat direction.
And that rods have
a push on that mass,
the mass pushes back on the rod.
So if in the theta
direction it's
like that, the mass pushes back
on the rod, it twists the rod,
or tries to.
That's a torque about this
in the r hat direction.
So there's centripetal
acceleration,
it takes force to cause
centripetal acceleration.
It's that force is inward.
It's about a moment arm
z, and so this gives you
a torque about the point A
in the theta hat direction.
So these are three different
terms, each one has a purpose.
No work is done here,
no work is done here,
because there's no movement.
Now, but gravity, we
started this question
as why doesn't gravity
pop out of this.
Because this only tells
you about the time rate
of change of angular momentum.
Gravity has nothing to
do with angular momentum.
r cross p is all that
angular momentum is.
The linear momentum of little
clumps of mass times the
radius from the point you're
computing the angular momentum.
Has nothing to do
with g, never will.
You'll never get the g
related static moment
out of this equation.
It's there, though, and if
you were designing the system,
you'd have to take
it into account.
So remember, I didn't bring it
today, but I have my shaker.
I've bolted it to the floor.
Inside of that shaker is
a little rotating mass.
It has a little arm
and eccentricity, it
has some mass that
I'm going to make m,
it's rotating theta direction.
And it rotates a constant speed.
So it's some constant omega,
theta double dot equals 0.
So I just got my shaker
bolted to the floors,
it's putting a lot of
vibration into the floor.
And the question
that someone came up
with on a muddy card that was
a really inside insightful
question, why-- or
they didn't say why--
they said, shouldn't
the torque required
to drive this thing somehow
be affected by gravity?
So does the torque
that it takes to run
this around and around
depend on gravity,
was the question that was asked.
Let's take a quick look at that.
We just discovered that dhdt
doesn't tell you anything
about torque from
gravity, right?
Well, let's see
what happens then.
So the summation of the external
torques-- I'll call this now
point A, where it's
rotating about.
This point now doesn't
move in this problem.
It's an inertial point.
Summation of the torques
with respect to A
is dh with respect to A, dt,
and there's no additional terms
because that
velocity point is 0.
And that's d by dt, the
torque is just r cross p,
so that is me theta dot.
That's the velocity,
that's the momentum.
I've left out something.
So r cross p, I need
an e squared in here.
me squared theta dot
in the k hat direction.
I need to take the time
derivative of that.
That's a constant, that's a
constant, that's a constant,
it only comes from this term.
And that gives me me squared
theta double dot k hat
direction, and that's got to be
equal to the sum of the torques
in the system, the
external torques.
And what are they?
So torques about this point.
So axial forces in this
thing contribute no torques,
transverse forces,
external forces only
come from the mg on this thing.
So my torques on
this system, there
is some mechanical
torque being applied.
That's what I'm looking for.
I've got a motor
driving this thing,
so there's some t of t in there,
some torque, minus mge cosine
theta is the moment arm.
So there's this force,
there's this moment arm
is e cosine theta.
So this is the external
torque caused by gravity,
but all of this equals what?
What's theta double dot?
0.
The external torque
is mge cosine omega t,
theta is omega t.
And so indeed, as this
thing goes around,
when it's coming up, you've
got to apply enough torque
to lift it against gravity.
When it clears the top,
gravity is helping it,
it's going down the other side.
So in fact, if you plotted the
torque as a function of time
for this system, it's like this.
It's just lifting
that mass up and down.
Then, of course, if
there's any friction
in this thing, et
cetera, it's going
to have to apply a little
bit of torque for that, too.
But indeed, this is
an insightful question
that someone asked, is
that the gravity does
have to enter into this thing.
So there will be a torque
that the motor has to supply
to drive this thing in gravity.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Should that
expression also have--
the expression for torque also
me squared theta double dot--
PROFESSOR: Ah, now
theta double dot is?
Yeah, see, it would.
If this thing was
spinning up and I
was trying to account for the
torque required to spin it up,
then here is.
Then I would include that, this
would be an equation of motion
that says all these
things are true,
and I can solve
for torque again.
And it will allow me to decide
how fast I could spin it up.
If I have a dinky
little motor, it
doesn't spin up
very fast, if I had
a really powerful motor that
could really put it to it,
spin it up quickly.
OK.
So now I want to move on
to the third topic, which
is to kind of go back to where
I left off last time, talking
about we need to move on from
particles to rigid bodies
so we can do more
interesting problems.
So I want to pick up with
the subject of angular
momentum for rigid bodies.
Now last time I just barely
scratched the surface of this.
And lots of muddy cards
said I don't get it.
I didn't expect you to get
it with it being half baked
and the first time
you've seen it.
So we're going to continue
and we won't finish today.
So let's think about
a general rigid body.
Here's my inertial system,
got a body out here
that's rotating
about some point,
A. A could even be
outside the body
and have it rotate about it.
And attached to A is
a reference frame.
Little x, little y, little z.
So my Axy frame.
Now, I put up last time, there's
two pages out of Williams
which gives the
equations for the moment
and products of inertia in terms
of summations of masses times
particle locations.
And in order to do
that, Williams defines
a coordinate system
on this body,
and that coordinate system
is fixed to the body,
rotates to the body,
and Williams calls that
coordinate system little oxyz.
In his book, he calls the
inertial frame big Oxyz.
It's really hard to do
that on a blackboard
and how you'd be able
to tell it apart, OK.
So I'm going to depart, and my
frame in here is an Axyz frame.
But A and o, if you're
reading that handout,
are the same thing.
A and little o.
It's a frame fixed to the
body that's rotating with it.
We can write angular
momentum for rigid bodies
as a vector hx having a
component in the i direction, j
direction, and these
coordinates as the product
of a matrix of constants.
And these constants are these
moments of inertia and products
of inertia terms.
And so forth.
I'll write out a couple
more of these, iy.
It's a symmetric matrix,
and you multiply it
by the components
of the rotation
that you are
rotating this object,
so here's a vector omega.
This object is rotating about
A, the direction, the axis
of rotation is like that.
And you can break
this rotation rate
into components
in the xyz system.
And that's what these are,
these are the components of it.
So you multiply out
this matrix in a vector,
you will get
individual equations
for the hx, hy, and hz
components of the angular
momentum of that object.
Now let's consider,
let's just do
a case where the spin is
only about the z-axis.
We do lots of these
problems, the book
has a whole chapter
on it and they're
called planar motion problems.
We just typically pick the spin
around the z as a convention.
And if you have a case like
that, then h here is i times
0, 0, omega z.
Then you multiply that out, you
get ixz omega z, iyz omega z,
and izz omega z.
Vector times the square matrix
gives you back a vector.
That's what you get back.
And if you want to write h as
a vector, which we frequently
do, h, now this is
with respect to A,
and we'll find that i here
as also with respect to A.
Have to be very careful in your
construction of this matrix.
It has to do with the point
about which you are computing
your angular momentum.
OK, if you want to
write this as a vector,
then this becomes hx i hat
plus hy j hat plus hz k hat.
That's just where the
unit vectors come in.
When you want to express
this as a vector,
you take these three components,
and these are hx, hy, hz.
This little double
subscript, the first one
tells you the component
of h, this is hx, hy, hz.
The second one tells
you the axis of rotation
about which the object
is spinning to give you
this piece of angular momentum.
So ixz is hx spinning
at rate omega z.
Now, the direction of spin was?
What's the unit vector
in the direction
of rotation for this problem?
What's omega?
We said we're going to start
off with just-- direction,
it's only spinning
in z direction.
So it's just spinning
But I multiply this thing
out, I get three terms.
And I get a term in
the i, a j, and a k.
Now these two terms,
so this is i, x is z,
omega is zi plus iyz omega
zj plus izz omega zk.
That's these three terms.
These two terms
exist because I've
assumed that these off
diagonal terms are not 0.
The problem we started with,
we started with an example
last time.
Our bicycle wheel thing with
the unbalanced masses on it,
we use the Williams formulas to
compute these different terms.
If the off diagonal
terms here are not 0,
then when you write the
angular momentum expression,
you get parts of
the angular momentum
that are not in the
direction of spin.
That's a really
important conclusion.
So the off diagonal terms
lead to angular momentum
not in the direction of spin.
And when you take
the time derivative,
you end up with torques,
and they're right back
to this problem up here.
If you have off diagonal
terms in this matrix,
when you spin it
around one of its axes,
it is dynamically unbalanced.
If these are not 0,
you spin it around one
of the axes of the system
for which these are defining,
in which these are
defined, you find out
that you get unbalanced
torques in the system.
So those two go together.
Now, another way of
saying that is any time
you end up with the angular
momentum vector not pointing
in the same direction
as the rotation,
then the system is going to
be dynamically unbalanced.
Actually, I kind of want to
keep Atwood's machine here.
So this was our unbalanced
bicycle wheel problem
we had talked about last time.
I can simulate that with this.
I basically have
drawn it like this.
So this is the problem.
This thing is
definitely unbalanced,
it's trying to do this
as it goes around.
And last time we
actually worked up,
from the William formulas, what
the moment of inertia matrix
looked like.
So now this xyz system
are attached and rotating
with that frame.
So my axis of spin is-- this
one's a little exaggerated.
That drawing is like this.
The x is like that.
So x is like this, z is
like that, minus x minus z.
So when this thing spins, that's
the problem that's drawn there.
And if I compute with those
with Williams formulas,
the various quantities--
so i with respect
to A for this system.
The first term, the ixx
term, is summation miyi
squared plus zi
squared, and so forth.
You get a bunch of terms, and
I will write out one other one
here.
This term over in
the corner is ixz,
and that's minus summation
of the mixizi and so forth.
And if we went through and
worked up each of these things,
i with respect to
A for this problem,
comes out mz1 squared 0
minus mx1z1 0 minus mx1z1.
The middle term mx1 squared
plus z1 squared, 0, 0,
and mx1 squared.
So that's what this mass
moment of inertia matrix
looks like for
these two particles.
So now if I want to
write the angular
momentum of this system
using this new notation,
I would say that it's
i computed with respect
to A times my omega, and
our case is 0, 0, omega z.
And if we write that out, we
do that, multiply that out, we
end up with a minus mx1z1 omega
z, 0, and mx1 squared omega z.
These are our three
components, hx, hy, hz.
And if you wanted to
write it as a vector,
then you'd add the unit vectors.
So the hx and the i plus 0
for the hy plus hz in the k.
So now if you went and took the
time derivative of those terms,
what do you get?
AUDIENCE: Torques.
PROFESSOR: Torques.
And you'll get 3 terms.
When we did the example a minute
ago, what we're doing here
is not very different from that.
You're going to get the torque
that it takes to accelerate it
around the spin
axis, but you're also
going to get the torque two
derivatives of this one, which
gives you two terms.
And these are the
moments of torques
about that center of
the axle, in this case,
trying to twist
the system around.
Now, reach some closure here.
We've got a good stopping point.
Here's our system one last time.
Here's the z-axis.
The angular momentum
that comes out of this,
you have a component
hz in the z direction,
and you end up
with a component--
it's got a minus in it-- in
the x direction like this,
so that the total h vector with
respect to A looks like that.
And it's not in the
direction of spin,
it's actually perpendicular
to our bar here.
And it's dynamically unbalanced.
So just to-- how do
we make the transition
from that to rigid bodies?
The Williams formulas,
that are these,
say that if you want the mass
moment of inertia of a body,
all you have to do is sum
up all the little mass
bits at the correct
distances off of axes,
and you will get it.
So when you have particles,
you can just add them up.
When you have a rigid
body, those summations
become integrals.
And, for example,
izz is the integral
of-- how should I say this.
x squared plus y squared
dm, every little mass bit.
It looks like-- is there
an exam some distance away?
I see a lot of people vanishing.
OK, so let me--
I'll tell you what.
I'll just make it easy
for it and let you go.
Let me just say one thing
to where we're going.
For every rigid body,
there is a different set
of axes for which, when you
go to make up this matrix,
you can make a diagonal.
And those are called
the principal axes,
and that's where
we're going next,
those play a really important
role in what we want to do.
OK.